okay welcome back everyone we're gonna
start our next class this evening and
this one I prepared to show you my game
from a twenty 2014 World Open tournament
[Music]
I'm playing against Grand Master Voigt
kovitch unfortunately he passed away
about ten years ago that was a very very
good player and in this game I managed
to win a nice positional game and but
there were some nice tactics in the
opening so we start out with the opening
and everybody here sure know the name of
this opening huh Slav raise your hand
kneel kneel Slav what Slav defense when
you're playing black there's a defense
usually right so when you're playing
white it's you know it's just opening
but you know with black usually it's a
Slav defense nimzo-indian defense so
it's lots of Defense's okay defense I
talk to little surprise to my opponent
what is the name of this variation of
the Slav defense that I'm playing now we
we know we establish the name of the
opening everybody Slav defense what is
the name of this variation should be
more hands should be more hands now
about this line okay we got a couple of
hands
klaudia probably knows this turn or
Claudia okay actually addict exchange
guys exchange variation of the Slav
defense everybody got it
exchange variation because after you
take you're exchanging it so you lead to
a kind of a symmetrical play fish per
four is six this is a very interesting
move it's a waiting move but it's also
useful at some point controlling the b5
square but what's the drawback of this
move
when you know that in chess every time
you make a pawn a move you weaken the
position right in here this pawn move
weakens something kneel
yes weakens this and now this square
it's more it's easier to access because
not going to be so easy to play b6
because of that weakness and now you
don't want to play III here because if
you play three he has a strong Bishop g4
so III is not good
III is out of question so the correct
move here is look to see one you're
waiting for the blocks next move
then you will play III okay because you
want to see where is he gonna put the
bishop on f5 or is he gonna play six
because he's not gonna go here because
that move runs into a very powerful move
which move I'm talking about this is not
good because this is not a pin you
normally it's good to put it there if
it's a pin so this is not a pin Ashish
95 absolutely and now Knight is very
active and this is vulnerable so he
plays Queen b6
yeah you played this move Queen b6
actually this is a pretty rare move I
don't think this is particularly a very
good move but he wanted to experiment so
how should I deal with this move what
should I do
because it doesn't look like it's it's
that easy right correct yes 924 that's
where I played temple gaining a temple
and hitting that coin so the point here
he's gonna give a check and now I need
to block this check somehow I cannot
block it with my queen because I drop it
so I have to either go back with a
bishop or Knight so new correct hitting
the Queen Queen goes back to d8 but he
wastes too much time by doing this and
now a very important move is Queen b3
activating the Queen and getting ready
to insert this Knight to a very strong
square on b6 that night will be very
very powerful and strong on b6 okay
Knight b6 attacking the rook and very
nice so he plays c6
Knight b6 has explained why in our play
three just trying to catch up on that
development I'm not worried about ninety
or five-year-old because I Bishop a5 so
I'm happy about that Knight e4 he's
activating his queen actually activating
the knight is this a correct move he's
he missing something here why to play
because looks bit dubious no a lot of
Queen moves are played and now he's
jumping in with no development bit
dubious how nil how you guys can try to
take advantage of this slightly dubious
play let's put it this way well got a
calculate Claudio Bishop e6 pawn takes
a6
rook c6 Bishop d7 and then you pinned
you cannot take the Queenie and if you
drop back not be should be trashy we
should the Trish of the normal move
calculate a sheesh and
rook takes p6 losing your night to know
thrush okay let's see here I want
somebody who can calculate calculate
couple of moves guys and find a way to
perhaps win win some material sorry
[ __ ] pay six that's the cloud you see
that fish pay six fish pay six rock c6
Bishop d7
sorry what
aren't you like losing some material
here yeah I mean if nothing else I mean
and if you start counting now extra
bishop right Ashish count counting
calculate Ashish can calculate remember
yeah alright so what did I play here
Knight takes d5 interesting suggestion
by Claudio let me take that first cloud
you and I know you have some yeah I know
that okay
so this is out right this move this is
out
what did I played Adi Quint xe8 nah
nope you need to have a follow-up aha
sheesh good work
98 taking the bishop so he cannot take
back with the rook because the pawn is
hanging here correct Queen takes one so
he has to take with a queen you're gonna
see that he took care first I took if he
takes now here what is the tactic that
is new right there yes Neil strong clay
yeah and now because the Queen is simply
overworked okay Queen is simply
overworked cannot move and you take on
being okay
take
maybe we should before he realized he is
losing a pawn so he decided in a let me
play this way so try not to lose
because the night is kind of trapped
yeah
pan takes the bishop D to check and wins
your queen
now you still want to get the top
position where you have that idea yeah
he had that dish p6 idea but he's trying
to make it difficult huh I think they
have another way to force it I think you
have another way Claudia to force him to
take on the two because essentially you
want to you essentially want the bishop
to you want to move the bishop from
there absolutely
a3 questioning the bishop and he has to
take it what else he can do he cannot
drop back on here because you have rook
c6 so he takes check and now again he
cannot take back with the look because
you take here so he has to take with
this and now you already know what to do
kneel yes bishop a six
he that okay at least this way now maybe
he will have some contra play or
something because my king is in the
middle and now I go back they should be
two of course if I can get my king to
gee mom I look over I'm just winning
here I'm up upon so he's gonna try to
complicate the position so if there's
Queen d7 now I want to do basically
castle by hand also we call the manual
canceling how we can do that guys kneel
Luke ht1
now I go squinty six attacking my pawn
in the corner the upon needs to be
defended protected how
what's the best move chiii blockading
the diagonal and again just couple of
moves away from putting the king in so
it is e 5 breaking take
King you wanna
now I'm just about to play King f1 and I
feel safe so he goes d4
now if they D for
absolutely Caleb that's exactly what I
did we need three forcing the exchange
because when you're ahead you're never
afraid to trade remember he tries to
keep the Nile but who is better here
bishop or a knight in this kind of
positions kneel bishop when the fight is
on two flanks or two sides of the board
the bishop is more powerful than but we
can also understand him if he takes here
not only he is down upon but look at my
rocks they're ready to come into that
seventh rank and up upon and with a very
big advantage winning endgame so you
went here now how we gonna win this
tough huh
Ashish the rooks belong we're in the
endgame seventh rank everybody should
remember that in endgame rooks belong
there now
pawn needs to be protected a king of two
rocky six
okay there are many ways how to win but
I choose just a simple pump it should be
5 now the night is passive and I look at
that fish crease attacking there
Bishop is always well placed on d5 it's
just centralized okay dominating that
night he goes here and now I realize
Rukh and game is winning let me just go
for it before strong rook on a seventh
rank extra pawn end of sixth weakness on
a six locate 6h for the rest is made of
technique age five attacking that book
to connect the past months and you know
the strength of those past pounds when
they're connected they're very strong
check King f3
a fourth I'm using this I'm using the
fact that he cannot just take on before
because the background check made so
that's why I push push
that they take on g7
and now how you want to try to continue
pushing those pawns because that's the
key to pounce you have to try to get
them pushed I could what else I want to
play a fire but I can't because the
b-pawn is hanging so what would be a
good way to do that
Adi correct now when your head you're
never afraid to trade and now time to
push further degrade strong further the
they get a stronger check see it's
finally the king is he cannot do like he
cannot even give me a check I've worked
his server so he went here connecting
them
what's the idea now yet
push push put the pants on a maximum
position caleb maximum maximise the push
okay now he goes here and he is trying
to get his own counter play but too
little too late
who is gonna find the finishing touch
here to score the victory here raise
your hands please raise your hand if you
see the winning idea here Caleb
perfect he resigned in a view of the
following variation takes takes
threatening to clear melody when the
past you have to pass on a six trunks
this past cannot be protected so now he
has to go here
okay
and now queen versus nice so that's
that's the end of the game okay so let's
go over this opening part one more time
so this this this was the important
victory
helped me to win the tournament so let's
go over this one more time go everybody
name of the opening slab defense what's
the name of the variation exchange
variation correct so now if anybody
plays the slab you have something you
can do something okay you can try to
play this this opening now what do we do
continue get the Knights out first
Ashish nights before bishops okay and
now with a Bishop fo now is six it so
used to move controlling the b5 square
but what is the drawback of this move
what is the drawback of this move Neal
weakens b6 and c5 absolutely so what do
we do huh
yes well he played he played here first
now attack in the pond 9a for excellent
checkup Bishop d2 getting a Tempe and
now a very important move here he wants
to get his Bishop out I don't want to
allow him to do that so which move I
have to play to do that
excellent Queen b3 not only putting
pressure also getting on b6 got it now
he goes he 696 excellent rook b8 Knights
Ashish 98 Queen see you not developed
yet so III first okay don't rush Ashish
Knight e4 and now Knight c8 again the
variation is the following if it takes
what do you do a D he takes a D and
that's the crushing idea okay taking and
winning everything so he takes
night xt2
Quincy eight perfect perfect
again again we're using the fact that
the overworked piece block has the
overworked piece and which piece I'm
referring to us overworked everyone
queen queen is overworked guarding this
and guarding this that's a typical
overworked piece okay for you so what is
the idea huh
Picasso's
we should be too
I'll get a she just yeah big difference
I'm a rook on an open file he's gonna
play e5 so he goes here
Queen d6 I actually thought about that
for here for a moment because it kind of
keeps a grip on it so probably it's a
good move as well a for I just didn't
want to weaken the position because he
really doesn't have much here if he
plays rook ft8 then he doesn't even have
that because of which move nice and we
take it with a rock okay
take take Queen III
it should be 5
before
Bishop III and once the bishop is
centralized on d5 its winning position
okay again my is a my game against void
kovitch okay from 2004 okay we have a
couple of other positions I want to show
you so we continue working on some of
this attacking ideas block to play this
one is blocked to play so let's spend a
couple of minutes here and try to see
how to win this position okay well
calculate Ashish a little bit I mean
there is not much do you don't have that
many options here so that's so that's
why this makes it a little bit easier
because there are not so many options
you have at the moment you have to play
like a grandmaster vladimir Akopian 2700
grandmaster
you have to calculate 1 2 for 4 months
Ashish you have for most that's where
the best defense I don't know what kind
of that means you need to do a little
bit more work the whole sequence is 6
months actually whole sequence that
results in a clear-cut advantage for you
ok
93 Ashish I think most of you were
calculating that correct okay
okay Bishop c3 yeah this is King a 1
sorry sorry one more time
Queen ji tool by Ashish
okay can I take this
huh well you might get made it now once
I got the discovery check out the rock
you gotta be careful you have to wake
whinge is 6 here and rock d3 okay it's
not so clear yeah
so this is not so clear okay what's the
question here we could but
Kinki - yeah but that's not so clear
there's a queen F for movin okay this is
correct guys this is correct right here
you just you just need to make sure
you're on rush here because queen g2 is
a very tempting move to play Bishop d4
now Queen D sixes
Rock dg2 here lukkage - that's correct
good job here now the threat is Queen Ji
Won check clean it three inmates so
that's correct
so now he plays here queen f1
I look chichi what is the threat rook G
- but you pray in the rook first right
yeah drop G 1 I woke Hindi - it's not
like it's a mate it's not a mate
immediately I mean you have some attacks
- but the rockin T - it's actually
correct
this move is the best move rook H -
because you're threatening you're
threatening you're threatening to play
Queen g1 so he plays this by Queen f1
and now new check f5 is hanging with the
check so you don't want to drop that
okay okay we raise our hands because you
just guys think moves and just raise
your hand if you think you have a good
move I have a threat of Queen f5 check
you don't want that to happen because
that could to reverse the color reverse
the roles of who is checkmating who so
please raise your hands yes yeah yeah
yeah check
and now it's unclear who is mating hell
yeah all right you don't want to draw a
sheesh
what is the winning move here Caleb come
on
excellent work f2 now the rook is under
queen is under attack if he moves the
way you got a queen g1 mate so he has to
go Queen here and check that's your
solution guys that's your solution
winning the Queen and the game got it
because the goal was to win the game or
at least the Queen you win the Queen
most likely you gonna win the game so
let's see how this happen again
deep calculation how park opium yeah
it's different
Wladimir a copy and you probably the he
was a finalist of the 1999 world World
Cup so the cold actually world
championship at the time so what's the
move continued nil
No
perfect okay excellent well good job
everybody thank you for joining this
class and we'll see you next week okay
[Music]